the cells
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
isn't it wonderful
in all the years we've been married
you've done some marvelous things this
however
is truly a miracle thank you nama
whatever whatever your name mrs noah i
love you mrs noah and i love you
shall we
yes
oh boy
that
is a lot of [ __ ]
i'm leaving you
dot com
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
that's called i just had one of one of
landau's mints and then the drink felt
very cold
my teeth just i feel like i have a
neurological condition
oh you thought that was a mint oh wait
oh that's on you yeah you're going to be
dancing in about a half hour well the
thing is that i've only been 34 that
have come before me
enjoy your nap enjoy your laugh i got
you a nut buddy look it's a shark it's a
makeover
so
i don't understand we have rand paul on
the show today that's right that's why
we're running a little bit late because
of technical difficulties because he's a
diva i i love him but he irritates me
so i'm glad that he has a new person to
irritate in
uh
fouchy i was debating whether i say
doctor yeah
justice fauci do well the science fact
yes mr science man yeah the second one
yes the science not like he's a guru
he's going to show up with a folding
chair oh no it's the science
off the top right
the man [ __ ] distracts the referee and
people still think it's actually
happening in alabama
yes wait it's not real that's his that's
his finishing moves he's putting him in
the flea cage look at him go he's eating
its face oh he's ejected him it's no
matter
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there are a few things to get to we're
going to be talking about roe v wade
today there may be an announcement from
biden uh former vice president biden
about new restrictions
it will be great to speak about that
with uh i was about to say dr fauci with
rand paul
doctor i think i have a migrant doctor
who had yesterday is it contagious i
don't know no but i have a few things to
get to look i have meds if you want one
well maybe but i don't want to fall
so a couple things the theme today as we
talk about abortion and roe v wade let
me be very clear of course i think we
should do away with roe v wade
but it's not what most of you think most
of you have no idea what roe v wade is
it has nothing to do with abortion we'll
get into the history of it and we'll get
into the legislation that is being
proposed and the mainstream position of
the left but the theme today is before
and after
before and after we need to talk about
what was happening before roe v wade and
after what was happening
before
we had all of the data as it relates to
the coveted vaccines and the old
microenviron and
after
what was what was a baby before 22 weeks
viability according to new case law
casey right casey versus uh planned
parenthood that's actually the law of
atlantis not really roe v wade versus
after viability a lot of people just
they talk about the before they talk
about the after but this is the only
case where this happens
before a murder that you commit
you are a law abiding citizen after
you're a murderer
before you commit grand larceny you are
a law abiding citizen after you are a
criminal but we don't set those same
standards as it relates to abortion and
that means even if you have a line that
is different than mine you need to
identify what happens when you cross
that line it is
beholden to the left needs to
be clear about what that line is and
what changes uh let me really quickly
before we get to anything else anything
else i will introduce you guys uh in a
second
i want to thank you
you watching listening right now uh
yesterday we asked you to
uh hit the like button and let us know
about
the snopes fact check yeah on nbc
following the jury we sent you there
okay this is why i'm so grateful for all
of you because uh before i left this
chair you
put enough pressure on snopes to change
their fact check so before that let me
remind you of what we talked about
yesterday what we requested of you hey
so mission control actually just sent me
a snips fact check and any guesses as to
what they said uh let me guess that it's
false that nbc followed the jury vance
so not exactly they actually said for
the claim in november 2021 an msnbc
producer intentionally followed a bus
containing chairs in the murder shelf
called rittenhouse unproven
oh that's odd what they said what they
said was in a statement provided to
cnn's brainstormed by msnbc they saw
stelter reliable sources right last
night a freelancer received a traffic
citation while the traffic violation
took place near the jury van the
freelancer never contacted or intended
to contact the jurors during
deliberations and never photographed or
intended to photograph them but that's
not what the name was about yeah
they found trying to follow a bus yeah
look everyone right now here's what i'm
gonna ask you smash the like button on
youtube
to confirm that you are going to send a
letter to snope
and then immediately
i think before i left this chair yeah
enough of you sent emails that they
changed the fact fact check to true
oh got him boom that happened fast that
was fast so look i'm going to ask you
again smash the like button right now if
you can
and comment below
if you sent an email here's the beauty
of this right and i always hate it when
you have other people who they they make
it about them and oh you know i have
this look
this has always been about and look at
the power of you we have the ability to
pull you we have access to more people
than most polling firms yeah that's true
and you are able to affect change so
when you think well nothing changes
that's a big one that's a big one why it
also ties into roe v wade because a lot
of people don't know this i will tease
this for you
ruth bader ginsburg
hey doesn't think what you thought
about roe v wade that's sort of the
sling but
i read the bible quite a bit all them
stories you told me about and
they ain't in there so i'll get to rovi
oh roe v wade in rvg
taters
[ __ ] queer funny not queer haha
not funny not haha funny queer yeah but
um's finest oh it's unbelievable
well here's the thing right now
at least as of this morning and this
will change i guarantee you after the
show i want you
to try this
and then let it let me know in the
comment section if you got the same
results if you search ruth bader
ginsburg ruth better ginsburg roe v wade
does not show up when i searched ruth
bader ginsburg r
ruth bitter ginsburg rovy wade did not
show up when i searched ruth bader
ginsburg row v google said
got nothing no clue
did you mean cats playing piano yeah if
i type in don it says donald trump
january 6th
oh
so we're going to get to that this is
this is the most important
war of our time is this this this war of
information that's going on right now
and it's not the lie that they tell you
it's the lie that you never know about
so we caught them yesterday you caught
them flat-footed and today we're going
to catch them again all right so before
we get to uh anything else we have
gerald a how are you i am well sir how
are you i'm okay i have like a headache
well why a little bit i don't know i
think it's because i was i knew that i
was going to be talking with rain paul
oh
wow listen steven thanks for making the
time but it wasn't the steven seagal
movie yeah that was pretty rough
hey
when you watch steven seagal movies
bad things happen you're gonna yes and
have a hangover to your soul you're
gonna like the way you look
you should totally be a warehouse guy
yes yes because i actually have to wear
warehouse size clothing
it dresses you like a geisha like he
does yes you're like what this is this
is like a biker geisha yeah yeah you're
like i don't like this at all i don't
like it well
that's because you can't pull it off
there's 11 buttons my yellow glasses are
glued to my head
if you remove my bifocals
my whole wig comes
dustin hoffman at the end of hook when
he takes off
you won peter so uh going to be in
springfield new jersey this weekend
tickets are now on sale for the majestic
theater in dallas february 12th yeah i
may be there just to let you know oh
yeah i'm thank you dave landau
ahoy how are you i'm good man how about
you i'm doing i mean i might be there to
introduce dave ah really
i would be honored if you'll have me i
would have you
we mustn't speak uh we mustn't get uh
pejorative bedroom talk yes i don't even
know what they're doing that's not the
proper use of jordan i don't care
i don't care
risque love now go go and be a good
little boy and have sex with your sister
so oh
what the let's make another king yes
true bloodline
that was that was the there was the
cider house rules but they meant it like
good night you princess of whales you
kings of new england
and i mean you are both because you're
both your brother sister and uncle good
night to all you brother uncle cousin
sisters
make more of you your family tree
it's you it's just you one branch be
careful of the edges you bleed that's
true yes more of a bonsai tree because
you and your sister see were twins you
shared
uh a placenta so really you're the same
the tree you have on your desk is the
royal family
yeah maybe they're in health of the
royal family as well
only kids can't come in and just you
know surround it for a couple seconds
and then it actually gains new needles
[Laughter]
what is it with charlie brown i you know
i don't know he's had a bad life yeah
rough rough go well he was abused i'm
surprised i didn't just shoot up to
school
too parents gave him rocks on halloween
like what'd you get i got a clark bar
what'd you get i got a snicker what'd
you get i got a rock what parents are
giving a child rocks no his own
psychiatrist would play a football prank
on this
all of this all the time just to help
your patients so i guess you're paying a
nickel but still oh she would be the
first to go if he went in oh he'll oh
yeah lucy pull that [ __ ] with the
football come on come on one more time
the football phone lions hand me that
hand me the blanket who's gonna make a
sport coat out of it
so
before we move on here uh
i'm just i am look rovi weight is one of
those things that gets me really pissed
so at some point i'm just gonna get on
to it and we're gonna let it rip because
it's just one of those things that you
see people outside of the cap protesting
they have no idea no they don't they
have no idea what it means they have no
idea what the case law is and they have
no idea
as to what actually constitutes
viability and we'll get into that but
before that this beautiful and brave
person is going to educate us on lgbtq a
a ip plus
i don't want to get fact checked uh
relationships so we uh well let's let's
take a watch
so you know how gay is non-women loving
non-women and lesbian is not men loving
non-men that would make straight non-men
loving non-women so if teen non-binary
people date they're both a straight gay
and lesbian couple all at the same time
so hold on i want to make sure i
[Music]
they're all gay
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay correct yeah
she could have simplified it just say
you're gay steven knows sexuality just
say you're gay that's okay
you do you oh also by the way i have no
idea if this is still going to be on
youtube uh hopefully uh it's yeah
rand paul we are now still complain yeah
but if you don't see this show on
youtube i just ran into a guy yesterday
at uh at the market
and uh he said hey you know i watch on
youtube so make sure you also watch on
rumble watch on mug club because monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern
unless rand paul makes us late
you can watch it if you don't see it on
youtube it is still going on unless we
tell you that we are missing a show for
things like christmas yeah yeah big news
too by the way rumble is going public
it's yes officially out there we just
saw it this morning rumble's going you
you said create our own youtube channel
are you accepted challenging by stock
at some point you'll be able to yeah
this caused a fight with my family
because uh they were like what's going
on what's going on with the rumble stuff
and i was like what do you mean i don't
know i have no idea like i've heard
rumbles about rumble i'm like i have no
idea humbly in the tumbly yeah that's
all it was well i'm buying stuff my
wife's like why don't you share with me
like because i could be hauled out in
cuffs
i could be in a dining souza ankle
bracelet that i have to blow into to
leave my bunk well i'm happy i'm happy
they're doing something to compete with
these tech overlords yes so well we just
saw that today snopes and mine snopes
google
facebook twitter they're all one on the
same these are the fact checkers that
are used
and twitter facebook youtube could ban
us and they do it all the time or ban
information that we get out because they
don't like what that information
reflects even though all reference is
available at lightweight.com and they
are used as the third party fact
checkers for the most powerful companies
the world has ever known you guys at
least yesterday got a win so take that w
um speaking of all uh the horrible
things uh christmas is going to be
ruined right now no no they're trying
we'll be getting the black santa in a
minute that's another thing uh not
because he's black just because we don't
need a black santa we got kwanzaa uh yes
you and four people yeah
it's just nancy pelosi in her desmond
tutu halloween costume and i'm here for
the party menorah thing
yeah yeah it's not a menorah okay yeah
what what is it
it's not a candle or a bra
okay based on african tradition okay
it's not made up at all juan zarachi
[Laughter]
all right so uh but black lives matter
is urging black people right now this is
the black lives matter their national uh
account on instagram they have like four
million followers i believe to boycott
white businesses oh really during
christmas it says oh it's officially
black christmas that was a horror film
by the way wait oh yeah christ
write the word christ yeah x means
christ they i don't think they knew that
and it says time to build black support
black lead serving organizations hashtag
buy black skip the black friday sales
and buy exclusively from black owned
businesses
black bank black move your money out of
white corporate banks that finance our
oppression and open accounts with black
owned
banks
uh this is one of those
they're saying boycott white businesses
okay
what about your gas
what about your electric what about your
internet by the way do you not see the
irony black lives matter in posting this
on instagram which by the way a majority
share is owned by a rich white jew
who also happens to be evil but not
because he's jewish no it's just
coincidence to be we have to we have to
fight white supremacy how do we do it
get your [ __ ] on instagram
if you have a publicly traded company
it's not a white it's owned by the
public shareholders like don't go to the
yeah don't go to the white owned
businesses it's like what what wind
chime stores yes is that what they want
you to do they don't want you to go to
their stores do we have a white
president
is a former
so technically what about government
assistance checks uh assistance checks
do you have to refuse those now because
it's a white owned white supremacist
patriarchy i didn't read the fine print
it doesn't count when it comes to the
money maybe it's representative
yeah it's oh oh that's reparation yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay not to mention this
is intensely racist
yes very much just don't buy from white
people it's insanely racist but also
what i'm not i'm just asking honest
question what what is a black owned bank
i don't know it's owned by black people
it's a non-credit union yeah but
i i don't know i mean like is there a
list no i'm just wondering if it's a
thing black i'm not trying to be i'm
gonna get in trouble no no i bet it's a
it's a credit score of uh 400 union is
it
oh stop it
i see the support i'm going to get
thanks thanks i'm really glad to see
that
cavalry coming over the hill
450. yeah well by the way that's also
something that they post about they talk
about how the credit system
they talk about how the credit system is
a form of white supremacists okay all
right this is something they actually
write about
okay
well calvary is where our our our savior
was crucified but cavalry i believe
oh but i do feel like i'm on calvary i
think we've all learned i don't know
words the skull mount
[Laughter]
so
but that's the true spirit of christmas
is making sure that we divide and
conquer by race yeah absolutely which
brings us to this now that uh disney
world disneyland they're they're hiring
uh black santas
oh good and uh before we get dave have
you ever have you ever seen a black have
you ever seen a black santa
guess if i'm in the wrong mall you uh
figurines at dollar tree
[Music]
we know you're watching oh it's funny
because it's true now this is here's the
thing i don't care
quarterback garrett yep
did you want a black santa what about
your full black relatives were they like
i don't want a black santa if you had a
black santa show up do you think you'd
be like oh that's one that must be one
of his helpers from the mall i mean
that's obvious all the ones in the mall
they're always the helpers yeah i i did
have a family member that had the black
santa like the glowing plastic black
santa in their yard uh-huh how did it
was a black light
ouch you walk by santa your teeth turn
blue
you could just see the hat
no he's smiling
here's the thing i don't care but this
is the most
this is the most blatant example of
cultural appropriation that i can think
of wearing a sombrero taco tuesday that
you brought that you purchased from a
mexican is not cultural appropriation
taking a historical figure who has been
an important arguably one of the most
important cultural icons of
western civilization and changing the
race is cultural appropriation i don't
care i just don't know why it's
necessary i don't understand why you why
people feel they need a black santa
claus yeah by the way it's for everybody
it's a clause if santa claus had started
out black i wouldn't need a white santa
claus no we need a white mlk junior well
yeah or a white michael jordan
i'm just i'm looking well there was
larry bird that's not there you go not
true but i understand where you're going
yeah no here's the thing santa is based
on saint nicholas okay santa's based on
saint nicholas this is an actual
historical figure who gave up his
belongings okay this was someone who was
you know venerated as a saint okay was
he white or black uh he was now some
people he would be mediterranean-looking
ah okay so in other words tsa would scan
him first cool
let's just turn that you know tandem now
the netherlands changed and he did adapt
throughout time to santa claus santa
claus i don't know how they pronounce it
yeah but the tale spread to the new
world where washington irving he
portrayed saint nicholas as like this
portly dutchman who would flew he would
fly these skies in a wagon and sure they
added reindeer and they changed it a
little bit with the coca-cola but yeah
you know what hey that's also a part of
american culture but again just like
boycotting white businesses from black
lives matter and now saying we need a
black santa claus first off this is not
in the spirit of christmas and santa
claus here's the beauty of santa claus
he is white
historically megan keller got into
trouble for that no santa claus is white
i don't know what race the bafana is i
don't care
just be true to the original yeah just
be true to the comics
now
the issue here is
you take something beautiful and you
ruin it think about it for a second
santa claus and i know a lot of
christians would get mad with the santa
thing because they would think that it
would conflate santa and jesus i'm not
one of those guys i think that santa is
a wonderful allegory for children think
of who santa claus is santa claus is a
jolly man who gives completely
selflessly with no expectation of
anything in return other than your
behavior to your fellow man not your
behavior towards santa doesn't matter
how you treat santa you never see santa
he only asks that you treat your fellow
human better by the way if you do he
delivers presents to everyone black
yellow red white unless your father got
laid off
no look here's
i have a good point here look if
santa was black from the beginning the
same people that said that santa should
be black now would be canceling him and
say you can't celebrate christmas with
black santa because they take they get
rid of uncle ben
and jemima true the same exact thing
they just say you can't celebrate it now
because this is our thing it's not
except they weren't even historical
references aunt jemima was an
inspiration there was a lady who was an
inspiration but enchantment i don't
think was a real person was inspired by
the individual
i know you want to because it's real
it's real very real don't tell me
another one well the issue here is a
bottle of syrup i like looking at her
yeah well now that syrup's boring i quit
pancakes well i know all together i mean
part of it was just her remember she'd
be at the table all animated yeah oh i
know oh talking like steven seagal yeah
each of me i can eat more pancakes
you like your pancakes you drink
yourself i'll break your hands i mean i
just drink the syrup yeah jeremiah sat
down and i used a pancake
as a napkin
his arms
the issue here is that people will say
oh the leftist are you triggered no no
no i'm not the issue here really is look
you're creating racism where there
doesn't need to be racism santa claus
wasn't created exclusively for white
people
okay white businesses don't serve
exclusively white people that would be
racist saying do not do business with
white people is also racist it's sort of
nearly racist well how about we just
start it right now we'll start a hashtag
don't support white businesses wait a
minute that makes us that's good
i know we're not good i hope you have an
armed helicopter i know eve you can't do
that no but and i would never dream of
that of course not i know you like
support white only you know what i'm not
white business black business big
business small business i support good
businesses yeah isn't that what the plan
was essentially based on exactly
businesses obviously but that was part
of it it was like are you serious yeah
have you not seen this record play
before well
i honestly don't care like if i bring my
kid to a mall and there's a black santa
there it's like you said you're gonna
have to answer some questions well yeah
i'm gonna be like look santa's helper he
may have taken someone's costume yeah no
something about the north african slave
trade the moors uh just like you know
but just go get your candy cane just
keep your dice
my son doesn't look at that like things
as color though he's he's sick all of
these kids will that's the that's the
problem
we grew up in a much more post-racial
america
i know i didn't have many black kids at
my high school you know what comment
below comment below if you're around the
age of 30 like i am um
i we didn't have any black kids in my
high school with a lot of asians we had
a lot of middle eastern kids uh we had a
lot of jewish kids
and we had a lot of indian we were just
we were friends with everybody and there
were a couple of black kids uh in our
great and we were friends with them it
was it wasn't an issue we didn't even
think about it the show that we watched
were fresh prince we watched family
matters we never even thought about it
now you don't you'll never have another
fresh prince of bel air you'll never
have another jefferson's you'll never
have another family matters what you
have is what what what you have b-e-t
you'll have tyler perry [ __ ]
and then you have white people stuff and
you divide it and now when kids are
being reminded of race at every single
turn and of course you're telling young
white kids that they need to check their
privilege and you're telling them that
santa claus is no longer a thing and we
need to make sure that guess what
happens
you you create
this
this
this paranoia of racial differences
where there don't need to be any and i'm
really worried that you're going to
create a generation of more racists than
any that have existed
since pre-civil rights that's a let me
know that's a genuine concern of mine i
talk with young kids and they're really
afraid
of the racial issue kind of like you see
you see young men now statistically
don't want to date because they're
afraid of being accused
i bet you're seeing some young kids
saying i just i don't want to step on a
land mine and so they just avoid some
kids avoid having black friends black
friends probably avoid having we
shouldn't have that we shouldn't have a
world where people are so afraid to
reach across the aisle and acknowledge
differences but that not all differences
matter all that much that's how we grew
up that's not how these kids are growing
up
well if you look at
even in the 90s i i saw black santas
this isn't this
new thing that right that's problems
they're making news out of it it's like
do you really think a black guy's never
put on a santa costume before right why
are you making this thing disney does
that with everything yeah they do we're
allowing black santas in our park
wow
whoa
that's so brave there you go racism is
over yeah thanks
ah let's watch your fouchy documentary
[ __ ] company sorry for my language i'm
really working on trying
spinner
[Music]
by the way actually we have if i'm not
mistaken we actually have i believe here
right now on the show before fauci uh we
have the first
ever i believe on the line do we
quarterback you yeah we do on the line
the first ever uh
real black santa he will be the actual
santa that good delivering presents this
year for an exclusive interview
[Music]
okay uh
mr black sam let me make sure that do we
have that connection yep it looks like
we got him here he here he is do we do
spot black santa yeah are you there
hello hey twitter worlds
hey twitter oh hi i mean merry christmas
stephen yeah okay you look uh
mr claus you look kind of familiar
don't be say we all look like that well
that's not what i said that's not lying
at all just don't let's we're live we
can't edit that uh
aren't you though aren't you um
santa aren't you o.j simpson oh no i
should know yeah come on now to the
world i'm fan of a black
black infantry black and claws okay oh
ho ho yo no that's definitely not
there's no black and claus is not a
thing oh you're you're you're o.j
simpson no yeah you are no now tell me
what you want for kwanzaa i don't
celebrate kwanzaa no one actually i was
like
right happy hanukkah then gold coins it
is okay that's a problem
oj why did oh
why did disney hire you uh i'm an actor
i was uh in the naked gun naked gun two
and a half and i've been acting innocent
uh for 25 years oh right yeah well
because
if if you did it yeah no i did what what
yeah if you did it yeah that killed that
[ __ ] okay well hey if he did i mean if
i if i did yes if you did i didn't know
a friend was going to be there i
did they get all the money from my book
if i did it because i i you know
so listen don't you think that disney's
hiring you is a little uh
based on your previous a little
dangerous why i never killed no kid uh
you're you're covered in blood uh right
now oh uh yes i am uh but but it's my
blood which means i gotta go get myself
to the hospital ho ho ho are you sure
they actually they have beds available
who cares they'll be white dancing
[ __ ] and that's all i really want
okay all right good luck good luck with
your job now oj bye oh ho ho ho stephen
but i'm gonna tell you i'ma [ __ ] kill
you one right oh
[Music]
he sounds kind of like a ladies man yeah
i'm not uh kind of like him i don't like
what's i don't like where our country is
headed no i i can't believe they hired
him i want to make sure i get it right
okay
hey you know what let me ask you guys
before fauci is coming on if he
is not watching the show
fauci rand paul yeah you did it again
the reason i'm saying is because on my
mind when i think rand paul he's
inextricably linked with how he is when
i think of rand paul i think of just
like well you are not the science i am
the science like in other words no just
rand paul there are caricatures of each
person it's a split screen of rand paul
and fouchy it just makes common sense
yes no it doesn't so i want to ask you
you know
rand paul uh we're going on the show we
don't have a lot of guests on this show
we have them maybe a few times a month
yeah comment below if you would like to
see more guests or if you you know and
like who you would like to see what you
would like to see is exactly because a
lot of people were like i just keep
doing this you know we don't necessarily
need guests we don't have people who are
here just to promote their book usually
we try and have someone who actually
provides
some value here i can't you know how
often we get the press token now and the
press releases were like so-and-so is
promoting their new book on i know you
want to have him on your show so he can
promote his new book promoting his new
book on how lgbtq aip are brainwashing
our children buy gold yes and catheters
who's writing the book g gordon liddy go
away now go away gee gordon pr firm
actually it's silver and caterpillars
bill devane
oh my lord oh
well by silver catheters but wait
they're self-lubricating if you order
now you'll get a uti yeah now they just
well they just brought back they have a
burl ives hologram once a doctor says
you have to use a catheter i'm going to
be like just give me enough pills to die
yes exactly i'm not kind of putting that
in and out every day right kidding me
yeah do what this is uh tell the good
lord i resign yeah boris kevorkian
tian need to see that other doc so roe v
wade here we're going to talk about
abortion and this right now the supreme
court case uh that's going on they're
hearing and people are concerned that
roe v wade is going to be overturned
that women are going to lose all their
rights that it's going to be handmaid's
tale um and leftists on
i guess mainstream media outlets so when
we say i mean you know okay in the
loosest sense of the word no one watches
them they're mainstream if you mean
someone stuck in a a layover in
charleston pretty much at an airport
yeah then the viewership is the nielsen
rating is off the charts but let's
look at some of the reactions
i would note that the president believes
since you gave me the opportunity that
the mississippi law blatantly violates
women's constitutional rights to safe
and legal abortions this case presents a
grave threat to women's fundamental
rights extreme republicans have attacked
abortion rights from every angle
and they are continuing their nonstop
efforts to build a country where
patients are forced to remain pregnant
and carry their pregnancies to term
against their will we have to pass the
each act and repeal high ensuring that
everyone has access to health care
brenner's not
now that's a conversation for another
day
it's shazam
she's a damn i'm sorry i getting moody
oh
why are you getting hungry i'm just yeah
i'm hungry i didn't eat anything today
why
but uh i i hate the last build bar oh
gosh he ate in well i think i think
there's one left yeah can i have it
there's one left like there's one
billboard but you know that's no i need
to eat two built bars why why would you
it's just that's the rule that's that's
in my contract could you crack it in
half i wish i could no
my contract says i get a build bar yes
but your contract doesn't uh i mean it's
non-enforceable
dude
i'm hungry i need your help well you
don't i don't think
i'm i'm unconcerned
i'm concerned well yeah because your
blood sugar might drop to normal yeah
well you know what yeah i might have
something i might have diabetes all
right yeah well you know what maybe
instead of a build bar you should eat
your foot you're going to lose it anyway
my doctor said i look like i have just
ladies
listen you guys know how to settle this
okay
that's true that's in both are kind of
like men
fine that's fair okay let's go
i think i don't know if i want to do it
you do yeah they'll
they'll settle this like
yeah it is but yeah just go
do we really have to do this absolutely
it's just insane well it's mentally
irregular but it deals a deal
should we have like helmets or like
boxing hats whatever no cte is not a
real thing that's just something liberal
people say
i don't think that's accurate why are we
covered in oil uh well i
have a lot of petroleum products in my
portfolio trying to create scarcity what
a boxing ring i just don't remember
putting it on
i still don't think this is a good idea
you just had heart surgery and i'm built
like a simpsons character i'm i'm
cleared for physical activity it's
besides we both need to get back in
shape it'll be a it'll be our thing
it'll be this could be our new thing
it'd be it'll be the thing that we do
together back in shape i need to look
over my contract
you want to ring the bell apollo
i was going to ring
i was going to ring the bell but that's
racist which we talked about but
huh you ready yeah yeah
ding
ding okay
come on stallion
hey you can lose this um hunter is
burgers
i think they feel longer i can't hear
what you're saying
hundreds biden's freebase filled lungs
is better than yours right now oh really
but i hope you're feeling good at cause
i'm about to smoke you like some cheese
yeah i like cheese you know but that's
the whole thing that's why it looks like
my favorite it's why i'm getting very
tired right now already
i'm
i'm really getting tired if you ate a
little less cheese a little more oil
boxing you probably wouldn't have this
problem i don't know why we are oil
boxing and why it's your thing well the
good news is after this we're gonna do
we're just doing a
in a shooting competition i got it
uh-huh i see a oh my inside's burnt yeah
well i just i don't know if i'm hungry
or it's just the way i've lived my life
oh
that's my bad knee uh oh
hey yeah hey yeah you know what i can do
i'm not here i can
i'll just go to gmc and pick up some
build bars oh cause they sell them
everywhere oh yeah that's a better idea
than fighting for the last one
you save your
save your breath you know what i'll do
is uh
i'll uh i'll have gerald sitting there i
have joseph first year he's earned it
he's earned it
[Music]
well
well
i'm full yeah look worse than that uh
you can go to built.com yeah enter the
promo code uh crowder15 to get 15 off i
have a box pretty
[Music]
they really are delicious
they really are that's the thing i put
them in the freezer and uh i eat them
they're like candy bars yeah i don't
know i don't i don't need the protein
bars just eating like another steak but
for me it's it's the only protein bar
they've had it's like as delicious as
yeah candy bars they put in real
chocolate so go to built.com and enter
in crowder15 it would
get the double i like the double
chocolate i like the cookie dough
and i like being dave in oil boxing ah
there you go i don't know if
it's more of a tie
what i mean you both kind of quit i know
majority decision
no
so not so much uh you just saw the
reaction from the left on abortion
and uh something else too i wanted to if
you can bring this up here token allen
is trevor noah also had some commentary
he's still a thing on abortion
apparently
he is bizarre he is bizarre he's trying
to do circa 2009 youtube videos but
doing it in a professional studio the
media just doesn't know how to catch up
they know about
as much as it relates to catching up in
the new media landscape as they do about
abortion and roe v wade and why it's bad
law but let's watch trevor noah for a
bit and i'll just tell you when to pause
it token ellen uh here are his uh
comments conservative movement is just
that dedicated to protecting life
i mean not protecting life from
coronavirus
or school shootings or from a lack of
health care or climate change poverty or
homelessness or and i know
okay this is something you hear a lot
from the left let me ask you this
what would be the difference i'm trying
to even go through all the examples
between that and abortion because the
left is there's a complete lack of
self-awareness and sometimes people get
tripped up on this i don't want you to
get tripped up he said coronavirus okay
there are a couple things that are very
different first off coronavirus the
vaccine that you would take for yourself
does not involve somebody else's body
also if you get vaccinated
it might have an effect on somebody else
a lot of the other issues fall under the
umbrella of taxation when you're really
talking about schools when you're
talking about health care okay it
doesn't involve
for me my own healthcare decisions as it
relates to getting a flu shot as it
relates to getting surgery as it relates
to my hsa my relationship with my doctor
i am not affecting somebody else and by
the way if the government paid for all
health care well empirically we know
that it wouldn't but their argument is
it might make other people more safe
climate change okay
climate change me driving a car myself
picking my own car picking the fuel for
my car picking how my house is heated
does not affect somebody else now you
may want to argue that if climate change
is the thing and it's man-made and the
green new deal will follow to a t it
might help other with abortion it's very
clear that it's not my body if i'm a
woman
you're a woman you have a baby in you do
you have 20 fingers do you have 20 toes
it's a boy do you have a penis do you
have two brains do you have two hearts
and by the way it's not it might without
any doubt you will destroy the life
of one that is not your own
that's a very notable difference it's
silly but it comes from
it stems from the issue that the left
does not understand liberty let's go on
to the next arguments that trevor noah
makes they're not really worth
addressing but it's so common that the
left is it must be nice to just be able
to destroy straw men let's watch it no i
know there are guys out there right now
who are saying well you know what tough
luck ladies but this doesn't affect me
well first of all you're going to see it
affect your bank account when you're
paying child support for 18 years and
secondly
you guys clearly don't see what's
happening here
yeah because first first they said a
baby is only a baby when it comes out of
the vagina then they said it's a baby
when it's viable outside of the womb
right now you've got people arguing that
if there's any electrical signal it
counts as a heartbeat you realize what's
coming up next right you know it's a
heart at some point they're going to be
like okay we decided that sperm is
babies all right so you can so first off
what
no conservative ever said only when it's
out of the vagina that's the straw man
yeah that's how you support abortion up
to and including nine months this
happens in states where the left has
complete control of the legislature just
to be clear and don't you love how the
left when they're framing abortion they
always address
the blessing the gift of being with
child
as nothing more than a burden
doesn't affect me well she's going to be
and these are words too that they use
force right you're going to force a
woman to carry a child it's important
we're going to do a whole segment on
these definitions force pro-choice okay
force no i'm not forcing anyone to do
anything
is she going to have to give birth
yeah
so you're no i'm not i'm simply not
forbidding her from ending another life
you want to force mandatory vaccines you
want to force mandatory carbon taxes you
want to do do you see the difference do
you understand the meaning of the word
force i'm i'm pro i'm pro-choice
you all right no hold on a second i'm
pro-choice
guess what four choices i just don't
support the fifth
abstinence contraception motherhood
adoption
murder's just not on the ticket that's
all
you want an extra one and by the way the
left
he says this is how conservatives
defined a baby right this is how he okay
hold on a second none of those are true
i will tell you how i define
a life it's at fertilization because new
dna is created separate from the mother
and father let's just set this up before
we get to the law okay here's the issue
trevor trevor noah
and nancy pelosi what do you define as a
life what do you define as a baby don't
get tripped up by this [ __ ] what do
you when is it a baby
they can't determine it what is it
viability because that's changed
preemies are being born earlier and
earlier due to different technology by
the way a baby who is premature at lenox
hill hospital in new york has a higher
survival rate with all the newest
technology and medical treatments
available to a baby born in the hills of
west virginia is one in life and one is
not hey look you want to say that
conservatives defined a life
whatever xyz way how do you define a
life they never do they can't defend
their argument with anything other than
abortion all the way up until and
including birth that's why the platform
has signed on to it yeah yeah but and
one of the things too we
just because we said okay okay okay look
you guys you're crazy but can't we all
just agree that if a baby can survive
outside of the womb that that's a life
we weren't saying that that was the line
we're saying that that is the least that
we can all agree on and understand is
absolutely a life right right it can
survive without the mom
can't we all no you can't agree no
that's that's where we were drawing the
line because we thought that was the
most reasonable possible thing that we
could say it is the most still thing
didn't get accepted well they always try
and trip you up too they go what about
rape and incest look don't get troubled
i'm amazed politicians do just do this
okay let's say we allow abortions for
rape and incest would you be okay now
banning the 99 point whatever other
percent of abortions yeah well no then
don't bring it up you're a liar
it doesn't even matter it's a lazy
argument so this is what we do with the
royal family well i'm not entirely sure
that you retroactive that'll
a few branches down the line true and by
branches i mean stump yes
so
count the rings yesterday the supreme
court
they began hearing the case of dobbs
versus jackson okay this is from a
women's health organization now the
dispute is a mississippi ban an abortion
after 15 weeks yeah okay
this case is likely going to determine
whether all sort of pre-viability
prohibitions on elective abortions are
actually unconstitutional so
that isn't necessarily the point as to
why roe v wade should be overturned and
by the way just to be clear overturning
roe v wade would not ban abortion nope
it would just allow the states
to determine abortion laws if you want
to get an abortion go to new york go to
new jersey go to cal i'm sure you're not
going to have a problem just to be clear
there is one group that is trying to be
totalitarian there is one group who is
trying to give undue power to the
federal government
just to be clear would not ban abortion
okay let's go to the history of ruby
wade a lot of people don't know i bet
you probably all think probably not
gerald uh but
a lot of you watching you probably
thought roe v wade was about the right
to abortion
you probably thought it was about the
right to sorry women's health pink tax
and [ __ ]
did you know it's not
it's the same reason that rbg
you're saying um say nicholas you have
rbg let's make her a black chick have
ever played by joy reid and biopic yeah
it's the same reason that rbg said this
is bad law it has nothing to do with
abortion roe v wade was determined on an
interpretive rite of the right to
privacy predicated uh on the 14th
amendment so let me give you some
history too there was an activist judy
smith
uh was looking for a case to legalize
abortion in texas was looking for a case
just to be clear and very much like the
the uh the gay couples were looking for
a bakery they tried to prosecute they
went to and fro was it the bakery the
pizza shop probably both i think it was
a bakery um smith needed a lawyer uh who
would take the case for free found this
person sarah weddington uh
the first couple that they tried to pick
didn't have any standing because they
didn't actually want an abortion yeah
they needed a case they were seeking out
already had a case yeah so they found
this pregnant woman norma mccorvey
who by the way never had an abortion
just to be clear
never had an abortion it's based on this
privacy law that was what was the name
of the the the uh the case in
connecticut uh griswold versus
connecticut yeah
uh and that's about due process due
process clause and privacy under the
14th amendment so roe v wade was women
have a right to privacy as far as the
privacy of uh their relationship with
their physician you know which is
that's very important now because it's
been rendered irrelevant right
all that because of mandatory vaccines
and vaccine passports and cards right
where where's my dupe where's my privacy
law i shouldn't have to show it ah you
do just if you want to do anything like
eat sleep drink or get on a plane in new
york or you know work out or
live you know be able to actually
survive
so anyway based on these arbitrary
timelines let me read you what the court
ruled uh during the first trimester the
decision to terminate the pregnancy was
solely at the discretion of the woman
after the first trimester
the state could regulate the procedure
during the second trimester the state
could regulate but not outlaw abortions
in the interests of the mother's health
after the second trimester the fetus
became viable the state could regulate
or outlaw abortions in the interest of
potential life okay look here's the deal
it went way too far abortion was they
were looking for a law to try and make
abortion completely legal in texas and
remove all restrictions okay so it went
to a federal level and the push was
effectively removing the rights the
autonomy of the states to have their own
restrictions on abortion yeah now this
one really this is why roe v wade needs
to be undone because it is an
infringement upon the rights of the
states but here's the thing
it's not just me who thinks roe v wade
went too far
take a look it's in a book
you don't have to take my word for it
what i said was
the court had an easy target because the
texas law
was the most extreme in the nation
abortion could be
had only if necessary to save the
woman's
life
it doesn't matter that her health would
be ruined that she was the victim of
rape or he says
i thought roe v wade was an easy case
and the supreme court could have held
that most extreme law unconstitutional
and put down its pen
instead
the court wrote an opinion that made
every
abortion restriction in the country
illegal
in one fell swoop
and that was
not the way the court ordinarily
operates
now just to be clear people got mad
that i posted some quotes from rbg
yesterday on social media they say
you're removing context actually i'm not
of course she was pro-abortion
if a woman like that are
oh
but
sorry
sorry don'ts don't speak ill
demons
that's who she's hanging out with but
she was saying i'm pro-abortion this is
bad law it goes too far so in context
yes she had a problem with roe v wade
for the same reasons that i have a
problem with roe v wade for the same
reasons that conservatives have a
problem with roe v wade you can have a
problem with roe v wade and still be
pro-abortion to some degree you can have
a problem with roe v wade and believe
that life begins at fertilization this
is a thing there should be some common
ground here if you care about the law
and something something something your
rights health care let me read you
another quote from rbg she said roe
isn't really about women's choice is it
it's about the doctor's freedom to
practice it wasn't woman-centered
it was physician-centered now here's
something else that you may not know
roe v wade is actually not the law of
the land as it relates to abortion
hmm there's been there's been a supreme
court case since then no you would never
know that from the media
i don't know exactly is casey versus
planned parenthood this supersedes wrote
why um
instead of referencing trimasters this
and by the way all references are
available at louder.com it prohibits
pro-life legislation before viability so
we've gotten out of the trimester
framework why because that's a losing
argument as technology improves um so
states can only begin to regulate
abortion
after the fetus has the potential to
survive outside of the womb
it's already rendered roe v wade
irrelevant just to be clear right a lot
of people don't know this they think if
roe v wade is overturned people are
going to be storming into your houses
and arresting you here's something else
that i sort of uh
i do have a question well let me read
you some uh um
i don't need to do it uh the first
premature baby was born at 21 weeks just
to be clear
okay the earliest that we've seen so the
earliest that we've seen so far just to
be clear and this is after legislation
was created so in other words
legislation was created say viability
and viability was later than it was
after they went ooh [ __ ]
because it keeps getting moved up
here's my question though i don't know
and if you're a lawyer and i i i i'll
talk with my facebook layer bill
richmond after this i don't know of any
other law that exists this way where it
says okay
you cannot write casey
versus planned parenthood the law states
you cannot
uh
regulate abortion at all
pre-viability right so they're creating
a line saying you can't because
pre-viability right that's
not a life okay
what about post viability
if you're saying that pre-viability is
inconsequential there's there's really
nothing determined as far as when the
baby is viable because they don't want
it's a touchy subject because you don't
want to say well yes it's a viable baby
that could live outside of the womb and
by the way we're going to abort it
anyway ralph northman had to deal with
those consequences along with being mr
blackface here's the issue
if you go into a story or a law-abiding
citizen we say that's fine the line is
when you
commit a crime commit theft you're now a
criminal there's a consequence if you
are simply walking down your street fine
you are a law-abiding citizen you kill
someone
there is now a consequence there's a
line now you are a murderer i don't know
any other case that says we're creating
a line what is it viability great so
there are consequences pre-viability
right supreme court yes
what are the consequences post-viability
exactly none
yeah nothing because apparently you're
you're ending a life right now wouldn't
that be murder
would if you're ending a viable life if
we've drawn the line wherever they
choose to draw that line we've drawn it
now you're ending a life and they're
pissed off at the texas bill because you
could be fined
ten thousand dollars right every murder
in prison right now is saying where do i
send the check let me out yeah right
i'll find 10 grand okay fine that guy
had it coming and to be clear no one is
suggesting arresting women who've had
abortion no no no
the the many kevorkians who perform the
abortion yes like freaking clones of
death doctors
yeah the gosnells i just don't know this
is this is one of those conversations
where you know you've heard me talk
about this
there's accountability only on one side
of the ledger and the accountability is
only with conservatives they're the ones
who say look okay this is how we define
a life this is where we are willing to
concede this is where we think the
states have the rights this is where we
think that the federal government is
infringing upon the autonomy of the
states okay now
what do you think about i don't know
it's like jesse ventura all of a sudden
i don't have the answers i'm just asking
questions
when do you think life begins
genuine question
we'll say my body my choice you have 10
you have an extra 10 fingers you have 20
fingers you have 20 toes do you have a
penis do you have two brains do you have
two hearts
when do you think life begins because
you've determined it's not a life
pre-viability
but then no answers for after it whereas
conservatives have to have an answer for
all of it including the 0.05 of
abortions that are extreme examples okay
speaking of a medical topic right now
yeah uh we have a doctor on the line i
believe do we have him we have him we
are going to go to uh senator rand paul
[Music]
all right senator rand paul he is on
twitter at rand paul let me first before
i bring him on um
he recently i just i
i mean i can't get enough of it we've
been watching these clips on this show
he's fantastic if rand paul ever retires
we'll lose like well just like cuomo if
cuomo was gone we lost like 30 percent
of our content and if rand paul retires
we'll get about that and we'll lose
about 20 of our mic drops
i know we need them or if fouchy runs
out of podlings well that's true yeah i
love that he just
makes fouchy
nervous i don't answer so let's just go
right here where he was uh uh rand paul
uh recently he blasted uh uh fauci used
that term appropriately just uh on fox
and friends about fauci claiming to be
the science
this is a very very dangerous sort of
idea the idea that a government
bureaucrat represents science and that
he is now untouchable over 100 million
americans have had covet they have
natural immunity there's a real question
about whether they should be vaccinated
once twice or not at all and the thing
is there's never been a debate because
he's the all-powerful scientist you're
not to question him just do as you're
told
and now we have him i want to make sure
the line was uh was all set up here
because we've had some problems recently
with the skype-ness senator rand paul
can you see me or hear me sir
i can see you i'm just disappointed that
i don't get any intro music what no
theme i don't i've been on the show
enough i should have my own music
well you know what we'll make sure that
it's uh bon jovi's dead or alive or
alice cooper's poison be sure to bring a
poll
um
i have got let me just ask you this
right off the bat because you happen to
be the person who's in the line of of
fire
uh when fauci makes the stupidest
comments
um
why do you think he has such confidence
that he is quote unquote the science
you know i think it goes along with the
personality
he's a government bureaucrat i mean he
works for the government he's a
physician but i think government
attracts people who think government is
the answer so i think whatever the
question is you ask him he's going to
think government is the answer and
usually the answer involves coercion it
involves restricting your liberty and
frankly he doesn't give a damn about
your liberty it's not in his wheelhouse
his wheelhouse is restricting your
liberty right and so i guess i'm not
surprised by it but the thing is is i
think the arrogance he doesn't realize
the arrogance of saying he is the
science
and also the the irony that if if he is
the science and he is the government and
the government determines what is the
correct science that it really is akin
to the medieval church deciding what is
and what isn't true yeah well when he
claimed that he was the science you just
saw kids drop out of the stem fields in
record numbers um
let me ask you this because you know the
omicron variant uh people are talking
about this right now and i was talking
about this as it was happening live
while we were on air and they were
saying well the vaccine work with the
omicron variant will it evade the
vaccine
i noticed
no one was asking
about whether it would evade natural
immunity
did you notice that and what do you
think the motive is it was striking to
me that it didn't even seem like it was
a question on the table
well
what was most striking is that we're
jumping to hysteria before anyone even
knows if it's deadly or not is it more
or less deadly than what we've currently
got
and before you say oh give them a
booster this is fauci's immediate
response give him a booster well does it
evade the vaccine completely if it is
the booster would be a waste of time so
we need to know is it more or less
deadly if it's more deadly i think the
best thing government can do is get out
of the way of the development of a new
vaccine or new monoclonal antibodies but
even that's premature because we don't
yet know whether it's more or less
deadly than what we've already got well
this whole confusion could have started
the booster confusion could have been
started by uh fauci wanted to ride in
the back of an explorer and needed a
seat
you just said is there a boost and then
everyone said oh we need boosters every
six months and you have to go along with
it to save face do you think
do you think there's a financial
incentive look i don't want to be
conspiratorial but people obviously look
at the look at the stock prices of
moderna uh these are issues that have
been brought up do you think there is a
financial incentive at least as it
relates to the legislation for covet
vaccines
i think the question at least should be
asked i mean for example the government
bought all the vaccines the government
bought all the monoclonal antibodies
since the government now owns it do they
feel somehow compelled to use it up
before we get any new stuff even if it's
not working very well i think that
question ought to be asked the delta
variant vaccine
we have had for
at least four or five months now it's
been in in phase uh one two three trial
it's in the it's in this hold on hold
senator rand paul because you just
touched on something a lot of people are
hearing this for the first time they're
going what does he mean he means the
vaccine if it works again explain
because most people don't know
what you mean by delta variant vaccine
that's a big deal
right so the the vaccine that we have
now was developed a year and a half ago
and it was related to the wild type the
first the first type of virus we got
the virus mutated and last summer the
delta variant took over so almost all
the infections in the united states
around the world are the delta variant
the old vaccine really probably provides
you some protection from hospitalization
and death but it's not stopping the
transmission of this and it's imperfect
i mean i think it's still better than
nothing particularly if you're in a high
risk category it's better than nothing
but the vaccine has evaded the the virus
has evaded the vaccine so they
they can sequence these viruses like
this omicron they've sequenced it within
days that means they could be developing
a vaccine next week and they're all
saying oh it'll take too long it'll take
too long well we've had a vaccine to the
delta variant for several months now
it's in testing but here's a question i
haven't heard one person on television
ask how come the flu vaccine comes out
every year like clockwork and we don't
seem to hear about testing and phase one
two three
why wouldn't they immediately allow this
as long as it's voluntary and say look
we've used the same technology all we
did was we swapped the wild variant for
the new variant and it's the same kind
of vaccine again but nobody's talking
about that nobody's talking about
letting that come to the to the public
and it might be enough to actually uh
stop the vaccine the way it was
originally the the first vaccine was
working well i don't want to get uh
too serious here but what you actually
just brought up is is scary to me and
and not good points that you brought up
but here's my concern in hearing what
you're talking about you're saying
they've developed the delta vaccine
months ago correct
yes okay
months ago
they were telling us dr fauci was
telling us
that the vaccine was perfectly effective
against the delta variant why would they
be developing something
new
while telling the american public that
there was no need for its development
that to me is terrifying
well i think part of the reason you
develop it is you develop it while also
testing to see if your vaccine works and
so it is a judgment call how well does
the current vaccine work against the
delta variant it works to a certain
extent but each month we've heard a
little bit lower percentages originally
you know the vaccine would stop 90
of people from getting infected then
this one was 60 you know it's more like
it's about 60 or 70 with a delta variant
my guess is that if you had a specific
vaccine for the delta variant you'd go
back up closer to the 90 percent again
and probably rotating in new vaccines
periodically like we do for the flu
would probably be a good idea but it
isn't amazing that all of the
prognosticators across all of the
different realms of the news media
nobody's asking why we don't have the
delta variant vaccine and why we didn't
use it and that question then comes is
are they worried about getting rid of
all the inventory of the vaccine they
already bought is that their concern
versus going to something that would be
more effective well but they were
telling people proactively that it was
effective and actually with with the
delta variant you know mayo did a study
with um and i'm familiar with mayo
because they just had titanium rods put
in and if i if mayo says something i
typically give them a lot i give them a
lot of credence mayo knows their stuff
they did a study with 50 000 people and
i can't remember it was the modern
pfizer one of them was 60 or 70
effective against the delta one of them
was in the four i think it was 42
percent this was
very very quickly after the delta
variant came out and i was always amazed
because no one talked about it and we
could get in trouble on youtube for
citing that study from mayo when it came
out until now they say all right you're
allowed to cite that study it's just
interesting to me that they were
developing uh a vaccine for that were
you about to ask something there gerald
okay you and i know that dave had a
question my two guys here they they said
you have rand paul we have a bunch of
questions like well he's a busy he's a
busy man well i have two questions i'll
go ahead and ask both of them at the
same time one is why aren't we talking
about uh natural natural immunity right
you've had covid the durability that has
always been the question i already asked
that you no no no but don't waste his
time he's a doctor and a senator he's
not going to place this where i'm going
with this is if we've had time to do all
of this testing like you said we can
sequence stuff in days we can have
alternative vaccines ready for delta
variants why haven't when we be able to
have we've not been able to do the
research to find out is this durable
because every time he talks about it he
says well the durability is the question
well that's i already asked that
question what's your second question i
apologize for his dumb ass what's the
next question i didn't hear an answer to
that question fine i'm sorry my show's
been hijacked
you know i think one of the things
that's important about all of the
vaccination hysteria and the hysteria
over this is that they're conditioning
you for submission it isn't so much
about the science or saving your life i
think it's conditioning you about
submission so for example the idea that
we should mandate the vaccine on
children is based on an ignorance or an
ignoring of the natural immunity of 100
million people but here's the other
thing every day on cnn i hate to bring
it up this horrible network that doesn't
tell the truth and spreads
misinformation
every day they say oh my goodness we
don't have enough people vaccinated
that's why we need a mandate i just
looked at the cdc website just a few
minutes ago between the ages of 64 and
75
99.9 percent of people have chosen to
get vaccinated can you imagine that
almost everybody between the ages of 64
and 75 have gotten vaccinated over age
75 it's 97
over age 50 it's 87
there's no lack of people being
vaccinated in our country
so why do they want to mandate to
condition you to submit to condition you
to that the central authorities will
make the decisions of your health care
and that's what this is about and that's
why we should resist because we may
eventually get beyond this but they're
going to want to tell you to do
something else in your health care when
they're done telling you to get the
kovid vaccine hey uh senator rand paul i
just want to ask you do you remember
when uh uh uh fauci mocked you for
talking about hurt immunity yeah i don't
know if you remember that he mocked you
for it and then he claimed that we
needed 70 percent for her immunity and
uh you know now we're with old people
but do you do you remember that uh when
he mocked you
i try to forget that
but uh
here's what i would say is it's
important for people to try to get their
news and we can talk about things on
here hopefully that aren't being talked
about here's another one if you look on
the official websites of the incidence
of the disease by state and the death
rate
something extraordinary happened in new
york
and i think it does have to do with herd
immunity if you look at the death rate
in new york it's been on the x-axis for
a year or more they had that huge spike
you know when cuomo tried to kill
everybody in the nursing homes right but
this huge spike
a lot of new york got this there are
parts of new york 30 or 40 percent of
new york may have gotten it my guess is
it may be what we should be doing are
antibody studies to see how many people
have had it in new york because i'll bet
you 50 maybe over 50 of new york's had
it now and you see the death rate it's
right along the x-axis well everybody
else has been going up and doing all
this new york hasn't really suffered an
increase in death rate because they had
such an enormous death rate at the
beginning right but they also got their
hurt immunity at that time as well but
they did see a spike in cases which is
why it's interesting as far as we're
talking about the vax the delta vaccine
not being very effective against
transmission you see that in a lot of
states where they reached a very high
level of vaccinations as well as
countries with very high level
vaccinations they did see a spike in
case rates now some of that could be
seasonal but you actually don't see that
same acute spike in some places where
they didn't necessarily have mandates or
the same rates the point is you can't
make an argument what i'm saying is i'm
not making an argument one way or the
other but one can certainly not make the
argument that reaching a threshold of
vax of this vaccine lowered case rates
and that to me is concerning
and the other mistake with ignoring
natural immunity is is that since it's
so potent and probably better than
vaccinated if we want to get to herd
immunity the natural immunity is
incredibly important it isn't wishing
that people get sick or get the disease
but the fact that they do particularly
those who don't get too sick and don't
die like the younger people is actually
better for society the more people that
have had the infection and survived and
that's really how we get beyond this is
when our natural immunity gets to a
point because in all likelihood we're
going to find that natural immunity is
significantly longer it already we think
is better but i think we're going to
find it that it lasts into the years
whereas the vaccine lasts six months
then you get another one in the last two
months then you get another one then it
lasts two weeks and before you know it
fauci will be mandating that we get
vaccinated you know weekly which is uh
ridiculous well that's just because it's
his hobby i have a couple of questions
here first off you're saying hopefully
when we find out and dave i do want to
get your question but i might not be
able to because i know the senator has
to go saying we
when we find out about natural immunity
um
why don't we do we have an answer how
many people have recontracted kovid who
had natural immunity do we does that
answer exist from the cdc right now
the the only place you can get it
actually is from the big israeli study
you know showing uh you know hundreds of
thousands of people that have not been
vaccinated they've kept track of it the
cdc doesn't keep track of it they have
no idea
they have no idea but see once again you
have to realize they don't care about
the science they care about conditioning
you to accept what you're being told and
it's better to have from their
perspective one size fits all because we
are considered to be ignoramuses
deplorable
unwashed uh
maybe even republican you know they
don't want these people to make their
decisions they think it's you shouldn't
think about this just everybody should
be vaccinated but it turns out it's not
good science and i think people will
reject it the more they hear about it
well i you know i will tell you this and
i'll go to dave's question and i'll
leave you with a very short question but
you know my father my mother got it uh
my wife had it we only found out because
i was feeling sick
and my wife said you probably have kovid
so we scheduled to go in the same day
she said if you have it i probably have
it i was feeling sick she was not she
walked past me at the clinic and she
said yeah i tested positive so you
likely have it and i went in the one
feeling sick and i did not
and then uh they said well you know what
it's just uh just treat it like a
positive because you're living with
someone who has it so you know don't see
your kids for ten days and don't go to
work and we had just had twins baby grow
and so then when it came to monoclonal
antibodies turns out i nev i didn't have
it by the way which i don't understand
because i was sleeping with my wife who
had it and we did stuff um they said
monoclonal antibodies when we went there
they said uh hey do you have a do you
have a positive test and i told them i
said well no but they told me to treat
it as a positive
and so they want this risk on one side
of it but they don't understand the risk
that americans are incurring just don't
work for two weeks just don't see your
kids and so my question is considering
all of these strains have been put on
americans and they feel it now there's
the omicron variant and i'll dave i'll
we'll talk about after i can't get to
your question
is there while we're talking about
science
is there any scientific indication that
the omicron variant is more deadly than
previous strains more of a concern is
this something new because i noticed
they're not talking about it so much on
cnn nothing this morning
uh nobody knows i mean we'll know more
in a couple of weeks and that's why any
pronouncements now are premature and
based just on sort of the
proclivities of people that want to
control your behavior but there's no
evidence yet and we'll know in a week or
two and if this is the black plague
i'm open to discussion as to what we
should do but if it's less serious um
there are a few brave doctors who have
said if it's less serious and very
contagious the fact that even more
natural immunity will be spread very
quickly through this if it's less deadly
it could be a silver lining you know to
this thing coming over here but the
other thing is it's already here the
banning travel is not going to work
i've never been for banning travel
whether it's a previous administration
or this administration just doesn't work
frankly but it cripples the economy of
tourism and the more they want to poke
and protest the less that people like me
who are independent-minded don't want to
go anywhere i mean i'm not going to
travel outside the u.s if they're going
to poke and prod me before i can come
back in
so frankly they're going to just
continue to hurt things around the world
as long as they overreact to things well
poking and prodding is kind of the razon
diet for fauci spent a lot of time in
bath houses senator rand paul that's
true you guys can look it up he wrote
about it uh thank you so much sir i know
you're busy i appreciate you actually uh
you know relaying some scientific
information here for our audience
thanks for having me and next time i
expect to have a musical intro all right
yes it will be dead or alive by bon jovi
just make sure to bring the tassels
senator rand paul everybody
[Music]
hey by the way i was leading the witness
yeah a little bit i was living the
witness on that last one for two reasons
i think he remembers
he said that to him yeah also there are
south african doctors who've come out
specifically and
said this is less deadly i haven't seen
any doctors specifically with experience
come out and say it's more deadly no
i've heard only people only experience
saying milder or silence kind of like
abortion right the burden of proof is
only on one side one guy's going hey
it's milder and then they're saying what
do you think fauci
do you want to know what the stat was
that sanjay gupta put up right as it's
coming out that you took my question
with the same [ __ ] question yes sorry
he didn't but he didn't ask the same way
i did that in my language you did not
you're irritated i am irritated i
understand i had a question what
no not for you
all right well you guys listen uh let me
know what you thought comment below on
the uh on dr uh dr rand paul is that
what's going on oh no oh no what's
happening where's that son of a [ __ ]
rand paul oh no no something to tell him
no i don't care hi
i'm the science that no dutch fat he's
an eye doctor and i say vaguely okay
that's enough